I don't know about you guys but I've
been hoping for a new live-action in G
Turtles movie ever since that
monstrosity and now we have one Michael
Bay produced yeah yeah it is but it's a
ninja turtles movie so we'll check it
out tonight Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
so Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles has a
long history of being Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and this movie has a long
history of being made it was gonna get
may then it wasn't gonna get may the
Michael Bay was like the aliens now
they're not aliens and now the movies
made and it's pretty simple premise four
turtles were raised by a rat they
learned in Jitsu now they're gonna take
on the evil shredder in the Foot Clan
because those bad guys are gonna be
really bad in this movie because they
watched the end of the Amazing Spiderman
they're like we can do that but in the
day time really funny about this movie
right off the bat I'm gonna clear this
up William Fichtner this dude said I get
to play shredder in the new Ninja
Turtles movie so that's interesting and
everyone including myself we were like
one and I'm telling you he doesn't he
does not play shredders shredders
another dude entirely and I thought they
were gonna do some weird things like you
know Joseph gordon-levitt and the GI Joe
movie where he's like oh I'm the doctor
I'm just a doctor and then the Andy's
like I'm Cobra Commander spoiler alert
for GI Joe if you give a [ __ ] so I
thought in this one bullying Fichtner
was gonna be like oh there was another
shredder but now I am the shredder
nah he's just a scientist guy who's not
Baxter Stockman when you actually have
Baxter Stockman in Ninja Turtles lore
who's the scientist that you can pull
from guys his other guy named Eric sacks
why huh who knows but he's in there
let's just break down the entire movie
for you right here first of all the
Ninja Turtles the Ninja Turtles the for
Leonardo Michelangelo Donatello Raphael
that were actually cool they were
awesome they were the thing in the movie
that worked for me Michelangelo is the
best turtle of them all which is fine
because Michelangelo and Raphael were
always my favorite too and it so happens
Michelangelo and Raphael are the two
best in this movie so that works for me
seriously though they did embody the
Ninja Turtles very well you see their
personality shine through you're like
awesome sometimes it feels like this
movies were relying on you to know Ninja
Turtles lora like Raphael this is time
where he's talking about all these times
he gave them a hard time and all these
times he was really a dick but you think
back in the movie and you're like not
just a couple times I haven't seen it a
lot you feel like the movies just
relying on the fact it was like well
it's Ninja Turtles you
all know that Raphael's a dick right he
likes to be alone right you know that
right but some people might not so that
whole monologues just kind of out the
window one thing I can say about this
movies everything is bigger sure does
bigger make better no to be honest with
you a few foot soldiers going into the
subway to confront April O'Neil and then
they knock her out raphael comes out and
just whips [ __ ] out of all of them it's
more interesting to me than all the
automatic wielding huge Special Op foot
soldiers putting c4 on the walls to blow
the [ __ ] out of the subway that money
can buy I don't want to compare this
Ninja Turtles movie to the last Ninja
Turtles movie or at least the first of
the last wave of Ninja Turtles movie I
movies actually still good now I've
watched that recently I'm like yep it's
good there's the theme of family in it
it has a good villain things work this
movies just kind of things are in it
like I didn't get the feeling that these
people were a family until later on in
the movie honestly when splinter comes
out I was like splinters a dick then you
end up liking splinter but at first he
didn't seem like this really wise wise
ninja that had all the answers he just
seemed like this guy he was gonna
chastise his kids if they did wrong I
don't like the splinter that chastises
like oh stand on your hands for 17 hours
now you'll learn your lesson douche put
your hand on Raphael's head and be like
I've tried to channel your anger but
more remains and it's gonna kill you in
Raphael's crying you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah that was in that Ninja Turtles
movie and it was good you can't help but
compare like content to like content you
have so many Ninja Turtles variations
out there you can't help but pick the
good ones and be like hey that's what
that could be
I'm a big villain guy I love a good
villain which means when you don't have
a good villain in the movie immediately
I'm check out Jason point shredder in
this movie he's just a big dude in a big
dumb robot [ __ ] costume and no one
cares about him seriously he had the
personality of razz are from secret of
the news I felt like he was the big guy
that the turtles would fight when they
take that big idiot down then they'll
actually fight the villain no that never
happened just strut it was just a big
dude to kick the [ __ ] out of him along
which shredder should be able to do
because shredder is better than
everybody which I understand why they
had to give shredder a big stupid robot
costume to fight the Ninja Turtles
because the Ninja Turtles are like eight
feet tall in this movie at that point
you have to make shredder huge and so
you can take on the Turtles because
Turtles hit someone they go flying
against a wall they're out all right you
have to make shredder huge so everything
is huge and everything is big and it
just doesn't have the person out it's
not a good villain just like all right
well
if you make shredder small what do you
have to do we have to make the Ninja
Turtle smaller all right we'll do that
and I'm not just saying that because I
really like shredder like shredders one
of the best villains ever because
shredders awesome because I like Ninja
Turtles lower and I like shredder I'm
saying shredder wasn't a good villain
because shredder had no personality in
this movie there's even one part where
shredders like tonight I dine on turtle
soup I was like that should have worked
for me and you didn't Megan Fox is April
O'Neil I mean she was funk she was about
as functional as I thought she would be
you have Maxim magazine beat off
material posing as April O'Neill in this
movie and she's about that efficient
yeah she actually does some stuff for
the turtles but this movie concentrates
on her job and then her and Will Arnett
yeah the movie did have some exciting
scenes you know the scene I thought
would be the shittiest scene in the
movie the scene where that looks like
they're on the Swiss Alps I was like why
are they on the Swiss Alps Oh going down
this mountain there's a huge avalanche
there's a huge there's a big action
scene what can I say that was actually
the coolest action scene in the movie I
was actually pretty excited then the end
of this movie I swear to God I said it
before I will say an app the end of this
movie is the end to the Amazing
Spiderman right down to the big intent
on the building that falls and you see
in the trailer like you saw in the
trailer - the amazing spider-man you
have to think someone that there's going
to get sued in the end Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles kids will have fun with
the movie sure but if you require a good
villain good characterization good
supporting characters no not this movie
the four Ninja Turtles work that I
thought they were the best part of the
movie in the end doesn't change the fact
that Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles would
be a lot better if you're drunk and I
was a party I don't play turtles in time
as the best hack and slash game ever to
be honest with you guys I am reading the
IDW Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles comic
book run right now and it's actually
really good no lie it's the right amount
of fanservice meets the right amount of
updating the story for you know modern
times and [ __ ] so of all the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles what's the one you
identify with the most in reality is
probably going to be a mix of two Ninja
Turtles what two Ninja Turtles make you
whoever they are comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you